You gotta be smart to be number one in any business.
But more importantly, you've got to play with your heart...
...and with every fiber of your body.
If you're lucky enough to find a guy with a lot of head and a lot of heart,...
...he's never gonna come off the field second.
And in truth, I've never known a man worth his salt...
...who in the long run, deep down in his heart,...
...didn't appreciate the grind, the discipline.
But I firmly believe that any man's finest hour...
...his greatest fulfillment to all he holds dear...
...is the moment when he has worked his heart out in a good cause...
...and lies exhausted on the field of battle....
...victorious.
Motherhood isn't always hearts and roses.
Mother's day can be with a bouquet from Teleflora.